Trascrizione: Eliana Zaccaro
Revisore: marshall8 mathers88
perché lo sport ha il potere
di cambiare il mondo.
Una frase semplice ma molto potente
sapete chi l'ha pronunciata?
Nelson Mandela, il primo presidente di
colore del Sudafrica che utilizzò proprio
lo sport e in particolare il rugby, per
combattere l’apartheid
e per pacificare il suo Paese,
facilitando l’inserimento,
pensate, dei primi giocatori di colore
nella squadra di rugby sudafricana, da
sempre composta solo di giocatori bianchi,
perciò innescando un grande cambiamento
culturale e lanciando un messaggio molto,
molto potente.
Il potere dello sport.
Stasera vi parlerò di questo.
Vi parlerò di come lo sport può essere uno
strumento straordinario per cambiare
la vita delle persone e della società,
come possa dare speranza,
combattere diseguaglianze e ogni forma
di discriminazione.
Da piccolo ho avuto la possibilità,
per fortuna, di fare
tanti attivita sportiva,
ma soprattutto ho avuto la fortuna di
avere sotto casa, vicino a casa,
un campetto di terra e sabbia
dove ho giocato
per anni a pallone con centinaia
di bambini del quartiere.
E lì ho fatto le mie amicizie,
quelle amicizie che ancora oggi
mi porto nella vita
e che si fanno quando si fa sport
insieme a qualsiasi tipo di sport.
Da lì lo sport è entrato prepotentemente
nella mia vita.
Ho studiato, ho fatto scienze motorie e
poi mi sono imbattuto in uno sport raro,
complicato ma meraviglioso dal punto di
vista formativo il pentathlon moderno.
Ma.
Cinque sport.
Ve lo dico io corsa, nuoto, tiro con
la pistola, scherma, equitazione.
Pensate la metafora della vita dal punto
di vista formativo straordinario.
E lì ho toccato la magia di educare
bambini e ragazzi attraverso lo sport.
Ho fatto l'istruttore, l'allenatore, il
tecnico federale, il dirigente sportivo e
poi ho fondato una società di pentathlon
moderno, non solo per vincere gare e
medaglie, ma soprattutto per regalare a
quanti più bambini e ragazzi possibili
questa opportunità così importante dal
punto di vista formativo, a prescindere
dal loro talento e dalle loro doti.
Dopo un po di tempo, perciò , dopo
vent'anni di questa vita e vedendo i
risultati e vedendo quanti bambini
e famiglie abbiamo aiutato anche
a superare i momenti difficili,
in me è nata
insomma una, chiamiamola una visione,
un'idea che poi è diventata una
consapevolezza e un'esigenza
da mettere in pratica.
Lo sport deve essere un diritto
accessibile a tutti i bambini e ragazzi,
soprattutto chi sta più ai
margini a prescindere.
Dalla loro situazione economica, sociale
e dalla loro provenienza
culturale e territoriale.
Questo questo volevo fare.
Da dove partire? Da dove iniziare?
Ecco, in questi momenti a volte
la vita ti manda dei segnali.
Tu di essere bravo a cogliere
e a mettere in pratica.
Intercettiamo delle fotografie di una
bellissima mostra fotografica
sulle Olimpiadi di Pechino.
Tutte fotografie sportive bellissime.
Quelle fotografie stavano per essere
buttate, ce le facciamo regalare.
Organizziamo un'asta di beneficenza e con
i primi fondi raccolti consentiamo
a sette bambini che venivano dalle
periferie difficili di Roma Nord di fare
attività sportiva gratuita.
Inseriamo nei corsi diventano modello
gratuitamente e poi siccome venivano da
contesti difficili abbiamo pensato che.
Fosse meglio avere accanto
allenatore una psicologa.
Così facemmo.
E come ci arrivano allo sport?
Già, noi genitori fatichiamo ad
accompagnare i nostri figli.
Prendevi il pulmino, li andavo a prendere
vicino alla scuola, li portava
sport, la sera li riportava a casa.
Conoscevo le loro famiglie, spesso
soltanto le mamme, e poi le visite
mediche e così via.
Ve la faccio breve.
A quel punto, insomma è stato.
E dirompente in me il fatto che bisognava
creare un’organizzazione
dedicata a questo.
E da lì, insomma, nasce questo progetto
con uno scopo ben preciso
un’organizzazione no profit dedicata ad
utilizzare lo sport come strumento
di inclusione social
benessere, educazione,
per aiutare bambini, ragazzi e famiglie
in gravi condizioni dal punto di vista
socio economico e a forte, forte rischio
di esclusione sociale.
Siamo partiti dal basso, non avevamo un
impianto sportivo,
non avevamo uno sponsor
e perciò è stato naturale unire
le forze, creare connessioni,
mettere insieme persone,
energie che credessero
come noi in quella missione.
Ed è nato perciò così un modello di
intervento molto, molto efficace, fatto
appunto da reti e da forti alleanze.
Una rete di enti, segnalatori, servizi
sociali, parrocchie, case famiglia.
Che ci segnalano i bambini e le famiglie
da prendere in carico.
Una rete di strutture sanitarie che ci
consentono di fargli fare le visite
medico sportive e di mandarli anche in
cura lì dove emergono patologie.
E poi una fantastica rete di associazioni
sportive e impianti
sportivi sparsi sul territorio.
Pensate oggi più di 200 dove noi inseriamo
gratuitamente i bambini e i
ragazzi a fare attività sportiva insieme
agli altri bambini che possono
regolarmente pagare la quota.
E poi una squadra di operatori incredibili
che sono psicologi,
istruttori sportivi, mediatori culturali,
educatori che seguono negli anni
percorso dei bambini e monitorano e
misurano
anche l’impatto dal punto di vista
psicofisico e psico sociale.
E anche dando un supporto come sostegno
scolastico, perché la scuola,
pur importante,
deve andare di pari passo.
Ecco quell'idea e quella visione
oggi è una realtà presente
in nove città italiane.
Dopo undici anni sono più di 5000 i
bambini, i ragazzi, le bambine e le
ragazze che abbiamo aiutato
attraverso lo sport.
E sono attualmente 29 le discipline
sportive differenti
che riusciamo a offrire.
Perciò non solo calcio dal rugby alla
danza, dalla arrampicata sportiva al
tennis, dal nuoto al badminton e così via.
E oggi ancora lavoriamo molto per essere
più efficaci, per inserire quanti più
bambini e bambine possibili.
Lavoriamo molto sul modello di intervento
e per avere la speranza.
Non la certezza e la speranza di
esercitare un cambiamento positivo nella
vita di questi bambini
e di questi ragazzi.
E ci siamo arrivati facendo degli errori,
ma nello stesso tempo oggi vi posso dire
che sono tanti i risultati positivi
e le storie belle.
Oggi ne racconto due La storia di
Sacio e la storia di Olya.
Il primo anno partiamo
pieni di entusiasmo,
non vedevamo l’ora
e inseriamo tutti insieme otto bambini rom
in una squadra di rugby di Roma Nord,
una zona bene di Roma Nord, diciamo così .
Dopo due settimane lettera di protesta
raccolta firme dei genitori gli zingari
insieme ai nostri bambini.
Evidentemente avevamo sbagliato, non
avevamo preparato bene l’ambiente,
siamo intervenuti,
abbiamo incontrato i genitori
e la società sportiva spiegando
meglio il progetto.
Abbiamo diviso i bambini in sottogruppi
in base all'età .
Abbiamo inserito una mediatrice culturale
rom sugli spalti insieme agli altri
genitori, che aiutava i bambini a farsi
capire e spiegava ai genitori
gli usi e costumi della loro cultura.
Spingo un bottoncino, vado avanti, Sacio.
È diventato il capitano della squadra
under dodici di rugby.
I genitori hanno fatto una raccolta fondi
per conto loro per comprare i libri
di scuola ai bambini rom.
E la domenica.
Al campo rom ci andava, ci andavano i
genitori del compagno di squadra che
andavano a prendere non il bambino zingaro
ma il compagno di squadra
al campo rom per portarlo alla partita
della domenica in trasferta.
Questo è il potere dello sport.
E poi come dire mi piace raccontarvi
quest'altra storia per farvi capire come
tutto torna e sia circolare.
Si riceve e si dà .
Olya, una bambina marocchina,
viveva in case occupate
in quartiere tosto di Roma.
La prendiamo in carico e la inseriamo
in corsi di badminton.
,uno sport piuttosto raro.
Lei si appassiona, rimane
con noi tanti anni, cresce
Ebbene, oggi è una ragazza iscritta al
terzo anno di economia e commercio
e da due anni è una delle nostre tutor
educatrici che restituisce ai bambini
quello che lei ha avuto
dall'organizzazione.
Ed è un'altra storia, molto, molto bella.
Ecco insomma mi piace raccontarvi
queste storie.
Per farvi capire che questo progetto lo
potete fare anche voi è un progetto per
come è strutturato che può essere
replicabile, deve essere replicato
e perciò come avviene nello sport.
La palla stasera passa proprio a voi,
materialmente passa a voi
una palla da volley.
Una palla da calcio.
Olè, è una palla da basket,
perciò la facciamo rimbalzare molto bene.
Affinché possiate costruire
le vostre reti,
attivare le connessioni giuste
e costruire il vostro progetto nella città
dove vivete oggi e dove andrete a vivere.
E sarà bello rincontrarsi
tra un po di tempo.
Io mi siederò da spettatore per guardare
la vostra partita
e per osservare come voi.
State dando il vostro contributo per
cambiare un pezzettino di mondo
attraverso il potere dello sport.
Grazie.
Punta
a.